notre panel d'analystes et là on
accueille tasha kheiriddin qui est à
toronto
bonsoir d'achat alors michel suau j'ai
comme d'habitude emmanuelle latraverse
ou six bonsoir à vous trois soirs
bon on a des chiffres à se mettre sous
la dent j'entends les gens dire non pas
des chiffres destin portal les cadres
financiers associés aux promesses aux
engagements c'est important dans une
campagne électorale
on va regarder ça ensemble vite si vous
voulez bien les tableaux on a le npd qui
dit que pour les quatre prochaines
années s'il est élu ce sera des déficits
ce serait des surplus 4 milliards 3
milliards 3 meyer 4 milliards et entre
autres pour les aider à obtenir plus de
revenus on compte sur l'augmentation
on va voir un autre tableau de l'impôt
sur les grandes entreprises
le pourcentage va passer de 15 à 17%
on a un extrait de du candidat 40 du npd
pour vient tuer d'après notre plan est
prudent équilibré et progressiste
contrairement à stephen harper qui
refuse d'intervenir dans l'économie et
contrairement à justin trudeau qui est
en mode panique
le npd va procéder par étapes de façon
prudente et responsable
alors la question évidemment sous
jacente c'était qui est posée au npd
depuis trois semaines
c est ce que vraiment on veut tous vos
engagements comment pouvez vous dire
vous ne ferez pas défier d'achat à
kérity mais ce que ça tient la route la
réponse est c'est ambitieux c'est sûr
mais ce n'est pas clair ça va tenir la
route parce que ça dépend du fait que
augmenter les impôts sur les grandes
entreprises vont pas avoir un impact
néfaste sur l'emploi par exemple ce qui
ferait baisser des revenus sur les
impôts des particuliers qui n'ont pas
d'emploi on voit que les projections de
la tdc sidatiques sur les quatre ans
l'effet qu'il prévoit sur sur ce point
là et aussi le fait qu'il ya des
programmes comme la peau du programme de
garderies on a vu au québec on avait
installé ce programme là une
augmentation faramineuse parce que tout
le monde voulait
y participer alors les coûts ont
rapidement grimper est-ce que ça va être
la même chose si c'est le cas ce serait
très difficile d'atteindre les objectifs
de la télé oui les garderies c'est une
des promesses maîtresse de monsieur
mulcair
michel c'est ce qu'on voit aussi c'est
ça qui va être intéressant je pense
parce que bon je pas économiste je vous
propose de vous dire que je le suis mais
quelqu'un d'entier apportait un peu au
québec une assez bonne réputation dit ça
parce que ça tienne cousin savoir passer
l'épreuve du temps bon je suis fier lui
ces convois qui va être intéressant
c'est les choix qui ont été faits le npd
fait carrément le choix qu'on peut
augmenter donc on doit augmenter des
impôts entre autres la taxe sur les
entreprises ça reste une taxe les plus
belles plus basse que celle des états
unis ça me reste un an de plus bas que
l'ensemble du g7 mais on la demande de
2% il ya beaucoup d'argent là on déforme
certain nombre de choses que monsieur
harper avait fait c'est à dire le
fractionnement du revenu
le plafond décennies on va chercher
certain nombre de sous là on veut et
tandis que monsieur trudeau 2010 bat ne
touche pas trop aux impôts et fonctionne
plus avec un déficit il ya vraiment une
différence de fraîcheur je file qui va
être intéressante à soutenir l'autre
chose qui marche peut-être moins c'est
qu'on prend les les prévisions du
ministère des finances du dernier budget
pour la croissance économique
on sait déjà que pour l'année prochaine
il marche mais alors on peut pas dire
que le bruit ça marche pas quand c'est
le gouvernement qui les fait ensuite est
utilisée soit même dans un camp nazi
on prend un peu ce qui fait notre
affaire croissance 1 sévit dans les bons
emmanuel c'est évident que ça sera une
des questions enfin les questions seront
posées à monsieur mulcair la tude demain
débat économique
demain soir est ce que vous croyez qu'il
est armé là pour répondre hier mais pour
dire regardez j'ai des chefs ça balance
on n'est pas dans le rouge et des
économistes qui me disent que ces
critiques dont seule une partie de
l'exercice de fait je vous dirai au delà
de la question du taux de croissance de
l'économique que soulever michel qui je
crois va être certainement relevé par
les adversaires de monsieur mulcair
le défi pour le pdci qu'on essaie de
présenter un cadre fiscal sans présenter
l'ensemble de la plateforme
et miss ou des rubriques qui sont pas
très claires et c'est ce qui fait que le
document est possible epide que ce genre
d'exemple la rubrique aider les familles
694 milliards de dollars l'an prochain
qu'est ce que c'est il paraît qu'une
partie si les garderies là dedans mais
dans les garderies l'an prochain c'est
seulement 300 millions de dollars
alors il ya plein de points comme ça qui
font finalement que ce document qu'il
faut le plus limpide que j'ai vu au fil
des ans fanny dans ce genre là et il y
aussi des réponses à donner par exemple
le npd dit qu'ils vont aller rechercher
240 millions de dollars avec la fin des
subventions des combustibles fossiles
d'où viennent ces chiffres les réponses
étaient peu claires dans la séance
d'information que tu as chaud corrigez
moi si je me trompe mais la crête de
plusieurs électeurs au canada anglais de
voir le npd prendre le pouvoir c'est
précisément cela qui est un qui est une
débandade peut-être de dépenses et l'ont
voulu rassurer depuis le début de la
campagne en temps contrairement à
monsieur trudeau nous choisi la rigueur
également parce que en ontario là où je
suis c'est clair les mémoires sont
longues on se rappelle du gouvernement
npd provincial de babré où ils ont eu
des déficits commençant immédiatement et
c'était quelque chose qui a plongé la
province dans le rouge depuis on est
encore dans le rouge en dépit du fait
qu'on a sorti un peu dans les années 90
donc sage ou encore vous dit toujours
oui c'est c'était quelque chose faire
d'eau qui porte le npd un peu partout
malgré le fait qu'il ait des deux
gouvernements provinciaux un td qui ont
bien fait et qui n'ont pas eu de déficit
mais c'est ils vont il faut faire la
preuve pour monsieur mulcair qui est
responsable sur ce score là et c'est
pour cette raison que je dis c'est
ambitieux ce qu'il fait il veut
démontrer que c'est possible de faire
des dépenses et sans déficit
encore une fois michel c'est le monde à
l'envers on le soulignait à plusieurs
reprises et monsieur trudeau pendant ce
temps qui dit mais moi je vais me
permettre de faire des déficits non pas
unanimes et trois ou quatre animaux et
lui il est vrai c'est de nous et nous
montrer un cadre financier parce qu'il
nous ramène toujours à ce qu'il nous a
donné le jour où il a annoncé ces
dépenses d'infrastructures bat
précisément il ya des choses qui c'est
qui va les changements qu'on fait
l'assurance chômage ça se financent de
telle façon donc on est passé dans
lequel financiers etc
c'est vrai pour certains points mais il
était clair qu'ils dépensent beaucoup
plus que ce que promet le npd jusqu'à
maintenant et il n'y a pas de véritables
cartes financières du côté du parti
libéral alors lui aussi randonnée va
devoir s'astreindre à cet exercice là
même si c'est de façon générale qui on
peut pas à mi campagne comme ça c'est
sûr qu'ils vont être pleins tout il
reste de trois semaines de promesses à
faire voilà et emmanuel là dessus c'est
un passage obligé quand même le bain les
conservateurs disent nous c'est notre
budget ouais les conservateurs eux s'en
tiennent au budget et d'ailleurs ils
n'ont pas dépensé beaucoup d'argent
c'est reparti comme de leurs offres dans
cette campagne électorale à dire écoutez
faut être prudent nous en dépenses à peu
près pas l'argent leur plus grosse
promesse c'est ce crédit pour la
rénovation domiciliaire est encore là
monsieur après addition va le faire
qu'on leur ait les moyens quand je
revenais sur plus donc moins de pression
sur les épaules des conservateurs oui à
un moment donné justin trudeau c'est
bien beau de rabat moi j'ai un coussin
de 10 milliards par année en déficit
vous allez voir tout ça s'équilibre ses
claques
oui lui aussi va devoir déposer son plan
mais je crois que comme au parti libéral
ont fait campagne sur le déficit
davantage ne fait un peu plus de marge
de manoeuvre que monsieur mulcair qui
doit convaincre d'équilibrer les livres
et de n'y pensez plus c'est pas la
quadrature du cercle et c'est cela qui s
est fait très bien
est ce que je fais et coussins et
séparés un coussin douillet a reçu une
balle on ne s'appelle pas ça peut pas
gagner plus gros que ça non plus et
c'est là dessus qu'on n'a pas encore eu
de réponse des libéraux voilà changement
de sujet le niqab on en parlait hier
rapidement ottawa va en appel va aller
jusqu'en cour suprême
cette histoire là on le voit on va
écouter d'abord les chefs convient j'ai
une question pour mon écoute rapidement
ici un gouvernement veut limiter ou
brimer des droits individuels ce
gouvernement se doit de justifier de
démontrer pourquoi c'est important et
nécessaire de brimer ses droits le
gouvernement de monsieur un peu ne fais
pas ça et n'a pas fait ça ils ont tout
simplement miser sur la peur
et la division comme ils le font
toujours le canada mérite mieux
nous avons la volonté ferme que ça se
passe comme ça et on va continuer de
l'avant bien sûr l'appel a été confirmée
le parc justice canada le gouvernement
du canada
on va laisser ce processus là se
dérouler mais pour nous lorsqu'on a
déposé au mois de juin ce projet de loi
est conviée affirme ce matin dans les
cent jours après notre élection nous le
ferons c'est pour nous une volonté ferme
de le faire pour lui céder à chacun les
conservateurs disent ce que maintenant
le premier skieur dit à l'assemblée
nationale à québec quand et 10 pour les
prestations de serment
on s'attend ce qu' il soit donnée bien
sûr et visage découvert est reçu à
visage découvert est-ce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de canadiens qu'ils avaient
dans le fond c'est le gros bon sens il y
en a beaucoup et il ya aussi beaucoup au
québec et les conservateurs quand cette
affaire est survenue la première fois
lors du premier rappel ont vu leurs
scores dans les sondages au québec
augmenté assez touquet qu'une question
qui résonne beaucoup dans cette province
là et alors ça pourrait potentiellement
les aider encore cette fois ci et c'est
une question aussi pour le canada
anglais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent mais oui pourquoi pas pourquoi
est ce que c'est il ya un refus là mais
il ya aussi la réaction inverse mais je
pense la base conservatrice certainement
et très du côté du ministre dans cette
question là parce que sur le spectre qui
à monsieur trudeau avait celle ci qui
lui enviaient de l'entente dis-nous
endroit est un droit et on trouve qu'il
joue dans des questions sacrée entre
guillemets même si le jugement ne porte
pas sur la constitution mais bien sûr un
règlement technicalité mais quand même
parlons du fond monsieur trudeau et de
l'autre côté de la clôture leylatul avec
plusieurs autres remet cela dit la
technique ali telle est importante c'est
une histoire entre une directive
ministérielle d'un règlement la cour
suprême
moi je serais vous pariez ne voudrais
même pas entendre la cause tellement ces
petits cette histoire là si on veut
alicante au fond si on veut interdire le
niqab dans certaines circonstances il
faut le faire avec une justification
la justification comme le québec
quelques mecs voudrait faire il dit que
c'est une question de sécurité que dans
des queues dans des services publics on
doit fonctionner comme ça il ya une
justification de sécurité sauf que dans
la prestation de serment
la question sécuritaire c'est
d'identifier la personne et ça c'est
déjà fait alors il ya beaucoup de
vérifications de l'avant histoire comme
celui là et si on veut essayer de la
ramener à eau c'est une question de
principe
vous allez voir que la cause soit vous
en trouvez plusieurs presse et il ya de
la démagogie manuel cambrai sur un
dossier comme celui là c'est évident oui
les conservateurs pour le calcul que
c'est ultra payant de faire ça je devais
écouter le jugement a été rendu hier au
moins de 24 heures plus tard denis lebel
et ou de tous les comtés au québec
louise était ou est ce qu'il était à
trois rivières c'est pas quel point il
pouvait me direz vous avec son candidat
dominique terriens qui veut dire que le
niqab c'est vraiment ultra important à
trois rivières oui ça fait partie je
pense du débat ce qui est intéressant
par ailleurs c'est que c'est une chose
pour justin trudeau de sortir la shark
les minorités et cetera mais on sent
quand même un certain mal à estang au
parti libéral et surtout ou npd parce
que c'est une question de principe pour
ces parties là mais ils sont aussi
conscients que dans ce dossier là la
position de principe n'est pas
nécessairement la plus populaire auprès
de l'électorat
voilà mes tâches à ce que ça reste en
quelques secondes ce dossier là ce que
ça va être un facteur ou dans deux
semaines n'a pas ou plus je pense qu'on
va pas trop en parler mais je pense
qu'il fallait en parler et le
gouvernement la nuit là parce qu'ils
savent que c'est comme on dit une façon
de gagner certains points et de
renforcer aussi le dossier de la
sécurité la sécurité c'est un dossier
qui est beaucoup ce gouvernement si
alors c'est à chaque fois qu'ils peuvent
le mentionner ils vont le faire
il s'est quand même jean patrice y avait
pas un mot dans le globe and mail ce
matin là dessus et un paragraphe dans le
toronto star et on en a par la cbi si on
en parlait hier je dis pas que je suis
tanné moulenda régler mais c'est quand
même pas la grosse affaire que c'est au
québec et même au québec
bon c'était dans nos bulletins on en a
parlé on a parle là mais ça pas été
parmi les trois grosses manches et de la
journée non plus ce qui est peut-être un
bon signe
mais là on verra on se reparlera de sang
ça ramène le débat qui n'est pas terminé
on dirait de la charte des valeurs à
chaque fois qu'on arrive avec quelque
chose comme ça il ya quelqu'un qui va
s'en saisir l'assemblée nationale je
vais essayer de faire un bout de chemin
avec alors là on a là il ya juste la
position de la politique au québec la
reprise des travaux parlementaires à
l'assemblée nationale d'une campagne
fédérale d'achats ça ça va vous allez
revenir dans cette arme à passer par byd
abl très bien alors on se revoit très
bientôt michel évidemment et emmanuel
merci à vous trois pouvoirs viendra en
vain